[Music]
okay everybody so this is the first time
that I'm gonna be covering this segment
which is called something about the
Romantic era so basically any game that
I show you has to involve some crazy
sacrifices from a very very long time
ago
and that you will see in fact I thought
I immediately thought of this game that
made a deep impression on me when I was
a young chess player just starting out
and I thought oh this must be the best
game ever played case closed
it is a good game but that's highly
subjective in any case as I continue to
improve I started to get this impression
that the Romantic era was kind of a nice
thing to think about but everybody
thought well you know they were playing
for the crowd that they weren't
necessarily playing the best moves and
in fact during the 20th century you see
a big shift from that romanticism that
would inspire people to attack at all
costs and sacrifice as much material as
possible took a 180 degree turn and all
of a sudden the best players in the
world were focusing on getting small
advantages and exploiting pawn
structures and winning long tense games
where you would get the impression that
they weren't doing anything they were
just sitting and waiting and capturing
the opponent's pieces as they made
mistakes and it seemed like it was case
closed the Romantic era was over
but then alpha0 came along and
especially with the advent of the first
computers and the first really strong
computers like Fritz Houdini and
stockfish people started checking the
games from their Romantic era and just
tearing them apart saying out all these
sacrifices are bad even tall sort of
like the last vestige from the Romantic
era he was wrong in half his games but
then alpha zero came along and just
trounced stockfish and it did it in such
a style in such a way that so unlike
computers that it just blew the door
open on what the future of chess holds
because I have the sneaking suspicion
that if alpha zero takes the games of a
lot of these players from the Romantic
era and of tall it might actually
correct the previous evaluations of the
other computers alpha zero might say you
know what tal was right after all
or zuker torte was right or more foo was
right because those evaluations done on
a strictly materialistic basis which
drives engines such as Houdini and
stockfish don't drive alpha zero because
alpha zero has different value systems
and obviously off of zeros onto
something because it beat stockfish by
like a score of a hundred and fifty five
to six which is pretty wide margin so
I'm very excited to see what they do
with alpha zero I hope they don't do
what they did with deep blue after it
beat Kaspari they just disassembled it
and hid it away in some warehouse with
the Lost Ark of the Covenant
so I do hope that they have alpha0
reviews some of these older games and
see if this theory actually holds up
that maybe the old guys were really onto
something because the future of chess
definitely seems like it's heading back
towards a sort of Renaissance of these
romantic ideas anyway I thought I would
show you two games one of them is this
game played back in 1883 between zuker
torque and blackboard and then I wanted
to show you one of the Alpha zero games
that made an impression on me as a
reinterpretation of this romanticism
from none other than a computer so I'm
gonna go through the opening fairly
quickly some of the openings played in
the 19th century actually hold up pretty
well today but that's going to be the
subject for another discussion
anyway so the sucker tort system is
actually is it this is a court system or
the Rubinstein system I forget I think
it's the circuit tort but it's a little
bit different than this usually it
starts by keeping the pawn on c2 for a
while so since we just finished a
lecture where the collie figured quite
prominently the other option that white
has here instead of playing c3 is to
play b3 and the point is to go something
like this and for example if b6 castles
Bishop d7 they be d2 Bishop d6 and 95 I
believe this is called a zuker tort
system I don't know somebody can correct
me if I'm wrong but it's a very
interesting system where white tries to
play for f4 and then a queen swing over
to the Kings side maybe some g4 g5 ideas
as well and you still see this plate
quite often
so that's just a quick aside but in this
game mr. Court decided to play with the
pawn on c4 and after Queen e7 Knight b5
it looks like black is able to eliminate
an absolutely fundamental piece in
blacks position which is the dark
squared Bishop because once white does
this not only do we secure the advantage
of the bishop pair but also black will
become much more limited in terms of its
possibilities of pawn structures right
without this dark square Bishop black
can no longer consider get embracing an
isolated Queen pawn for example because
an isolated Queen pawn without the dark
square bishop loses a lot of its sting
so very likely instead of Queen e7 black
should have taken some precautions with
a6 just to make sure that this Bishop
can stay alive of course
if white had tried to play Knight b5
here this Bishop could have retreated to
e7 so it's not a big deal so let's see
what happened 94 Knight takes pawn takes
92 and I have six f3 takes takes this is
a surprisingly mellow game for a
Romantic period it seems like white
secured the bishop pair and then just
started manoeuvring and nurturing the
advantage this is what you would expect
from Petrosian rather than zuker torpid
will see that the game soon starts to
get quite entertaining
so after DC for Bishop takes c4 d5
Bishop d3 rook
f2 c8 rook 81 so I think this is where
white starts thinking of this position
in a very ambitious way I think a lot of
players would have simply played rook a
c1 fought for the C file traded off the
rooks and tried to make the bishop pair
overpower the bishop and Knight and some
very boring endgame however rook a e1
intends to play the movie for key 5 and
later f4 f5 and as we saw previously if
we if white managed to get a pawn to e5
that's immediately going to provide
white with some excellent attacking
chances because the f6 Square which is
the natural defensive square for the
Black Knight is going to be under
control so this Knight is probably going
to have to go to d7 and f8 which is far
from ideal
so after rook c7 white played efore and
after rook c8 d5 so everything's under
control and I really like this idea of
ignoring blacks play on the C file
because the bishops do a really great
job at controlling the entry points so
the C file is open but not really it's
not open for business because there's
just no good way for the rook to break
through and after 98 f4 so in a couple
of moves White's position went from
being oh this is going to be a nice
comfortable endgame to okay I could win
in 20 moves well we're actually out to
move 20 so maybe in another 5 or 10
moves so g6 rookie 3
f-5e takes f6 Knight takes f6 and f5 so
very nice pawn break it's so much so
move that looks very nice but not a very
hard move to find right because the pawn
is pin then if G takes f 5 simply Bishop
takes and the more the position opens up
the scarier these bishops look so
instead black had planned to play the
move Knight to e4 which seems to make a
lot of sense because now if you have to
go Bishop takes b4 which is what
happened in the game D takes e4 and you
lost the bishop pair and should black
managed to block on d5 this Bishop on b2
won't be able to participate so well in
the attack
so FG six and rook c2 has anybody ever
seen this game before oh my goodness so
I'm gonna have to be careful with you
guys
so what would you play here do you
remember exactly what white did or do
you vaguely remember the game and
alright so it's good so we can try to
figure it out together so at least I'm
not alone that it made an impression on
you when you saw it right yeah
and it actually reminds me of that
puzzle that you showed the other day
with the crazy pins everywhere you know
I think diagonals are an important theme
in in this game as well so I mean what
what moves would we look at here as as
white
what's that
yeah so take the pawn right keep opening
some lines with checks so we can deal
with this problem of our queen later but
okay King h8 and now we can't really
delay this uh this issue anymore
what's that I can't quite hear you
yeah yeah okay so d5 and after E 5 so d6
let's see can they create some problems
for you
so after d6 the point I guess is if I go
rook takes D - you're gonna go D takes
c7 and if I go rook takes B - you're
gonna go rook f8 and that's it right so
what else could I try to do here can I
try to go Queen g5 or Queen g7 Oh
because now the queen is hanging the
rook is also hanging on III and we're
getting made it on G - any ideas or
should we go back where roof g3 okay
wait be careful if I guess we can take
here and then if you take here here
what what's that yeah
Bishop g7 here here this looks pretty
dangerous so I should probably be a
little bit careful here do I have to go
Queen takes d2 I could also try this
right and and if take stakes or I could
I could also try Queen takes g3
absolutely so it looks like allowing
this black queen to come to g5 provides
black with moves that allow to defend
and attack at the same time so very
dangerous any other ideas
boom Queen B 4 so very similar idea to
the one that Ashish is that the one that
you were saying before when we were
looking at d6 Queen g5 rook g3 you
wanted to give up the Queen in order to
allow this Bishop access to the e5
square so you're onto the right idea but
the best way of executing it was right
away with Queen B 4 and this is a a
great example of that I like to use
whenever I'm trying to illustrate middle
games or attacking positions where
opposite color bishops are on the board
another great one is Stein it's against
Lasker from a Scotch opening but that
one is a little bit more mellow where
Lasker just needs to work the position a
little bit more it's not so heavy on the
tactics but here after Queen before we
get a beautiful sequence after rook c5
how should white play here
it's at a hand yesmy
don't turn around I'm looking at you
yeah you okay I thought you were raising
your hand I didn't want it I didn't want
to leave you hanging any ideas yeah
Brooke g3 okay and let's say if Rick g3
can we go Bishop takes d5 or maybe rook
takes oh no I can't do that
maybe rook takes B - I don't know why I
didn't say where it takes B two starters
so yeah
very interesting and if I go Queen takes
and King takes h7 yeah and it looks like
like all of whites firepower is coming
into the game right because if we go
here then we're gonna get checkmated and
if we go to h6 well we should also get
checkmate in here right rook h3 king g5
well this is where oh this is even
faster well it's actually the same thing
huh
so it's still made in two so that's
right
rook F a very nice deflection but black
plate King takes h7 Queen takes e4 King
g7 where rook g3 King takes f8 bishop
takes e5 King takes f8 King e8
what's that
Oh at what point King d7 so what which
move are we looking at Bishop takes
right so King takes King here
so the thing is that you've given up
some material here so if I go King d7
you want to go rook f7 is this so clear
oh because you're gonna go Queen d6 I
have to be careful with that huh what
about it if I go here King takes takes
and then I take the bit I take the rook
and if Queen takes then I just take here
yeah
so rook f1 okay fair enough
and can we try this again Oh nope but
then Queen takes with check what am I
talking about so you're threatening rook
g3 or queen g4 hmm can we take this
bishop mmm that looks really strong here
rook h3 if I have to do this that's
pretty sad yeah real cafe oh right right
you still have Bishop b5 as well
rook g3 so King h8 yeah I mean this is
over
rorke f1 looks like a very interesting
move
hmm
yeah it sort of keeps everything all the
threats in the air and on top of that I
mean we're up a couple of ponds so this
is definitely game over in the game
white took on e5 and played Bishop g7
which is sort of a letting down the
hammer even faster right so the point is
that you're going to lose your Queen
because if you take here then Queen e8
checkmate
so black played King g8 and after Queen
e7 just resigned now the reason I'm
showing you guys this game is because
even though I believe we're at a sort of
Renaissance of the Romantic period at
the very early stages of it the type of
romantic games that we're gonna be
seeing in our times is going to be very
different so yes there will be material
sacrifices but the way the game will
develop will be very different so I
wanted to show you this game between
alpha 0 and stockfish we're gonna go
through the opening again fairly quickly
but if you play d4 with white and if you
don't know what to do against the
Queen's Indian I highly recommend the
games that alpha 0 played against
stockfish he completely wiped stockfish
off the board in the queen's indian and
all the games involved like sacrifices
of three four pawns of peas it doesn't
matter and the way that alpha zero
appreciates the compensation is based on
two driving forces number one is king
safety and number two is just achieving
a nice bind on the position so if you
have your king slightly exposed and
you're kind of cramped alpha zero will
give you all the material that you want
it doesn't care it considers those two
actors just to outweigh material very
heavily as we'll see in this game so
this should be seven castles castles d5
and this is a well-known theoretical
line that involves sacrificing a pond so
this is not an innovation by alpha zero
at all and these positions I'm actually
played them with white and a very rarely
sacrificed pawns in the opening are very
annoying to have to play with black
White's gonna go efore Knight c3 Queen
g4 Bishop h6 work 81 White's position
has a very nice flow to it
but if you're playing against the
computer we see the computer always
favoring these lines where if it's not
absolutely clear what you're getting for
the pawn it's gonna take it and hold
onto it so that's why this match
I believe introduced us to a new
paradigm in chess because we see this
clash of materialism against like meta
materialism that alpha zero has ushered
in so after E for Bishop f6 96 I'm
pretty sure this has been played many
times let's see probably tons of games
[Music]
don't know what databases is linked to
but okay there's only three that's a
little bit surprising
so Bishop a6 rookie 198 b5 takes and
here we see the first really surprising
moment in the game each takes f6 Queen
takes f6 so now we're down to pawns but
okay we have the bishop pair blacks King
safety isn't an issue yet but we are in
the early stages of getting a bind on
blacks position especially these pieces
that seem to be out of the game and also
this knight on d6 which looks a little
bit loose so let's see how alpha zero
keeps increasing the pressure by the way
there are some moments in this game that
I have absolutely no clue what's going
on so that's gonna be my disclaimer ice
I've played over this game many many
times and I still can't believe that
White's position is good something half
of it
so Bishop c4 h4 typical alpha zero move
just okay I'm down two pawns I guess
I'll just play h4 gained some space
hopefully threaten Bishop g5 which is
definitely a threat now and provoke h6
and now b3 let's turn this off all right
so after Queen takes c3 Bishop f4 so now
we're down to pawns and a piece okay we
will be getting our piece back bet it's
probably gonna involve giving up more
pawns
right because after Knight d7 B takes c4
Queen f6 now if stalkerish didn't take
this bond it's probably a really good
reason for it
so what's that
okay but how do we take advantage of
that
yeah I mean I'm sure that if against
rook c1 you would take this pawn I agree
you would go for it but I'm thinking
white can also try to take advantage of
this Queen by playing something like
rookie four and then trying to take on
h6 I don't want to presume that I have
any idea what alpha zero is thinking
because I really don't and I would
already start asking myself as stuff
like this doesn't work either
right cuz after pawn takes rook e4 now
you don't even have Queen d5 because of
the discovery
so instead black went Queen f6 and now
Bishop b4 and this is really the kind of
Romanticism that I think is coming our
way where the sacrifices will not be
based so much on variations but rather
they will be intuitive we will have to
take a leap of faith and believe that
when you have three very important
pieces that can't get out and a
potential attack on your opponent's king
then that's going to equal eventually a
one-game so I believe accurate
evaluations are going to be more and
more vague and the ability to recognize
patterns attacking patterns long term
attacking patterns is going to be what
the world's top players they're going to
be required to to master so Knight a6
Bishop b5
well this is a pretty straightforward
tactic right if Queen takes white simply
wins the Queen
so black plays Queen e6 and now Bishop
d3 so again threatening a discovery on
the Queen
so black plays f6 and now Bishop d4 and
after Queen f7 Queen g4 so whites pieces
keep creeping closer and closer to the
black King and also now we see that the
advances h6 and f6 have created a clear
target and this is a typical square that
we would use to create a clamp on a
position right if we put a bishop on g6
we see that this King on g8 is
undergoing to be under constant threat
of back rank problems so after a rook at
FD 8 rookie three Knights e5 and Bishop
g6 Queen f8 and rook d1 so the game goes
on as if nothing had happened
rook b8 King G 296
Bishop's III I love this quiet
maneuvering when you're down to pawns
and by the way this is not an exception
to the games that were playing in this
match has anybody looked at the entire
match or the entire match hasn't been
published they've only published some
twenty games that alpha zero one but has
anybody seen them no maybe one or two
Ashish you said you saw one where with
the rook sacrifice right
yeah how about there in the back was
that a hand no well I highly recommend
you guys check these games out there a
glimpse into the future in my opinion
and I remember when this first happened
I thought oh it's kind of a publicity
stunt they're trying to sell a new
engine or something like that and when I
saw it I realized I'd never seen
anything like this before the games are
just unreal and I would say this is a
one of the milder examples but it's one
of the simpler ones too so the game went
Knight bc5 rook de one night a4 and
Bishop d2 so now that the bishop has
done its job
along the a1 h8 diagonal by done its job
I mean provoked this weakening move f6
so that we could land our Bishop on g6
the bishop comes back to d2 and we'll
probably start threatening rooms like
Bishop takes h6 this reminds me of a
typical pattern you see in isolated
queen pawn positions where usually
White's light square bishop will come to
b3 and the point of putting the bishop
on b3 is to put pressure on f7 and when
black has a pawn on g7 you'll have to at
some point deal with the pressure by
playing a 7 to e6 and then once that job
is done the bishop simply returns back
to c2
and actually it's the other way around
it's on b3 it goes to c2 to provoke g6
and then it comes back to be three to
create sacrifices on e6 and I think
there's an analogous idea going on here
where the bishop has done its weak
weakness provoking job on c3 and now
it's simply going to come back and
create some real threats so King h8 f4
Queen d6
and Bishop c1 94 rookie 7fy
whatever our computer starts returning
material that's a sign of impending doom
right
most of these engines are programmed to
have material as the sole driving force
well king safety of course is up there
but they will never give you back the
material unless there is an immediate
threat or they just don't know what to
do and I think that the second case is
what's going on here
Black is just shuffling back and forth
with the pieces it looks like the
Knights have gotten a little bit more
active but really they're not doing
anything
so after f5 Bishop takes f5 Knight takes
Queen takes rook f8 rook takes d7 rook
f5 rook d6 so white trades into a an
endgame and you would think oh the worst
is over because well if you go c5 trying
to hold on to your pawn you might start
to realize that this night is still out
of the game and white can simply play a
rook d7 followed by a rookie to e7 your
knight can never come into the game with
Knight c3 because it's gonna run into
Bishop b2 and everybody's ganging up on
g7 pawn so this endgame is actually over
so white simply traded off into a
winning endgame and it doesn't feel like
a computer game it feels like a game
that any of us could have played
downstairs during a you know a rapid
game even so after rook f7 g4 not even
taking the pawn on c6 now after rook
takes c6 what do you guys think alpha
zero could have been concerned about
what's that and what counter play might
that be okay so you're saying you're
saying this move maybe
and ideas that what you were gonna say
Knight c3 okay and if we put a bishop
here can you take this you're gonna go
for it
yeah because I mean this doesn't seem
like such a big deal right now we have
to move the rook maybe here yeah maybe
we can go h5 h6 something like that it's
certain
ya know okay so let's say I go here I
guess
you bring your night out right yeah I
mean it still looks pretty good for
white we're up at pawn and we have
pressure against you seven but maybe we
can do better maybe not maybe against
this King h7 we can go here this one
well here I'm going to take right but if
you go night before the point that I was
trying to make is that maybe I can do
this
but you do have a 93 moon although I
could probably just go here
yeah in any case it still looks like
White's position is pretty good so
instead of rook takes c6 what I was
thinking was maybe it was worried about
h5 clamping down on some light squares
here but I don't know I mean I'm looking
at rookie five and this looks looks
completely waiting too so it's a bit of
an enigma every time I go through these
games I try to understand what these
moves are about and it's not easy at all
so King g8 and g5
so notice that alpha zero doesn't really
care about material unless it advances
its two goals of clamping down on the
opponent's position and attacking the
king if it's if it doesn't do those two
things it's sort of oh why would I do
that right and instead here we see that
with g4 g5 white is trying to get the
pawn to g6 and renew this pressure along
the back rank so take stakes 95 King f3
Knight p7 Merc d1 after Knight a5 rookie
for c5 Bishop b2 knight c6 and g6 there
we go
so the idea has been carried out even
though the material is even we start
feeling another clamp coming on blacks
position this pawn on g6
will again renew the threats on the
black King on g8 so rook c7 King g4
Knight d4 and rook b2
rook f8 Bishop takes pawn takes and moon
takes so now white does take the pawn
after having secured the pawn on g6 and
we enter a rook endgame which are
notoriously dryish but I was very
convinced by what I saw from White's
part basically any rook endgame where
you're down a king is going to be a lost
cause so King g5 rook f8d two rooks II
6:45
this is just
that is an unanswerable question at here
instead of a three
I really don't know why it played a
three if I was playing with white I
would already start thinking about
trading off some rooks maybe doing
something like rook here in order to
play either rookie a Tour rookie seven
we'll see you in the game something
similar okay so a three Brooksie seven a
four so there you go that's your
explanation the point of a three was
surveying no wasted attempt oh no I'm
just kidding
there's no point so a six rook d4 rook
c8 rookie five yet these maneuvers drive
me bananas but okay the rooks got traded
off this is what I would have tried to
do I would have tried to trade off one
rook and and highlight the fact that I
have an active King my opponent has a
passive King I have an active rook my
opponent has the passive rook this
formula for rook end games almost never
fails
so rook e8 usually in a rook end game
you would be willing to sacrifice a pawn
just to get active so in this position
if White was down a pawn white would
probably still be winning or much much
better the fact that material is even
just makes it worse for black so Brooks
c6
very logical what's that
I'm sorry yeah I meant to say like if
white were down upon instead of up upon
it was opposed to material being people
so you might a tricky six I have no clue
white you wouldn't go rook c6 here
what's that
no it went rookie six and after King f8
then rook c6 I don't know I mean how do
you stop anything it basically just the
only thing rookie six does is forces
your King to f8 what you would think is
useful for black right just to get the
King out of that mating net but now King
F for King new seven takes here check
and after King d5 it just resigned right
takes takes you're gonna get checked
your pawns going so I'm not a fan of
chess computers but I am a fan of alpha
zero and a lot of people are worried
about the future of chess because of
engines they think Oh engines are just
gonna work it all out and it's not going
to be fun anymore but it seems like the
way that chess is going to get worked
out is not necessarily by forced
calculation but rather by just some
intuitive attacking patterns like we see
in alpha zeros games so do we have any
questions before we call it a night
no we're good okay guys so thanks for
sticking around and I'll be seeing you
around this week in the next couple of
weeks as well alright
you
[Music]